pas parfait on commence dans trente
secondes
je dois faire appeler l'hélico
[Musique]
alors sur ce tour du monde du canada en
images c'est votre émission de
télévision web en direct de montréal il
est 11h15
on est aujourd'hui le 26 avril le temps
avance et on filme les personnes plus
âgées
pour les plus jeunes y'a pas de souci
c'est les choses sont plus calmes
bienvenue à l'équipe de table dans le
canada aujourd'hui on va parler d'un
sujet qui va intéresser toute la planète
est une histoire qui est né au canada et
qui prend de l'ampleur
évidemment il ya que moi qui connais le
sujet des missions mais je me tourner
vers notre chef chef web vivant de
quelques courriels qui ont circulé dans
la semaine
oui dont vous connaissez le sujet dont
je ne connais pas je suis complètement
confuse et je pensais le savoir il ay
vous avez mentionné quelque chose depuis
l'âge qu'on fait ce que vous pensez que
vous allez participer au jeu de la
découverte du sujet des missions ça sent
que ce soit injuste pour les autres
oui ouais alors on est tous prêts à la
maison au bureau dans l'avion le 737 on
regarde le sac images on voit de réaux
aujourd'hui on va vous proposer donc ça
dure pas très longtemps ses quarante
secondes pour devenir sujet des missions
vous crier dès que vous pensez être sur
la bonne piste
on regarde ça donc réfugié renfort oui
c'est vous êtes 11 et mills et rappelant
la cible comment vous faites rien là la
scène les premiers
d'accord je sais pas réfugié enfants
arrivés au canada ccvm bouquet nadal a
cédé réfugiés c'est l'accueil des
enfants d'immigrants a provoqué des
radios à ok tu veux le dire
radi au dodo cette première radio
internationale sont les enfants les ont
pas fait de dommage et c'est ça c'est à
dire quelque chose et puis c'est une
main tendue vers le canada pourra amener
les jeunes enfants en situation de
guerre à travers le monde il ya des
millions d'entre eux à avoir un moment
de paix de calme le soir ou la nuit en
écoutant la radio
en tout cas on va leur poser la question
j'imagine oui vous et moi je ne sais
rien je suis comme vous ont touché le
siège de cette radio c'est la question
dans quelle région du canada avec nous
en avant d inviter à l'appel aujourd'hui
mais vous allez accéder la grosse boule
ou et de l'émission pourra juste grosse
boule à chaque émission à chaque mission
il y en a trois vous perdez des points à
chaque tour là seulement 20 points terre
voici notre premier jeu on affiche sur
l'écran et on va demander à tiens donc
samir ben alesi ou lisez la première
question aussi je vous donne son canari
ça s'en vient et un avenir quelle grande
personnalité canadienne fait partie de
l'équipe de radio de dos à roméo
dallaire ex commandant de la mission des
nations unies pour l'assistance au
rwanda bernard de rome ex présentateur
de nouvelles télévisées à radio canada
ou bien c'est louise arbour procureur en
chef du tribunal pénal international
pour l'ex yougoslavie alors rodéo
derrière bernard de rome louise abour
qui fait partie des équipes de radio de
doux moi je dirais ben moi aussi
pourquoi 81 parce que c'est un ancien
journaliste présentateur
une expo à gérer ses lourdes basses
c'est comme ça elle veut instaurer la
justice on en interne c'est pas encore
ça veut dire que romain au moins deux
personnes de la cette émission qui va
perdre ses points aujourd'hui 20 points
peut-être parce qu'elle est roi vous
êtes cernés par les avait pas de dégâts
mais je voudrais que assez par roméo
dallaire hockey basculera radio de roméo
dallaire
j'avais de la difficulté à faire
l'équation quoique aux mammouths et oui
tous les mariages sont bons mais la
nature
vous savez c'est bizarre je vous propose
de regarder cette vidéo on retrouve
l'équipe de radio de dos une partie en
tout cas aisés les voir apparaître la
réponse
ça vous va oui vidéo numéro 2 partout on
écoute ans mamadou dodo et sans but
lucratif et l'initiative est patronnée
par la commission canadienne menée par
des prochaines joutes in bed and à la
bernerie et nous notre co animateur
bonsoir mon alors vous avez repéré avec
mario et luigi qu il fallait bien un
professionnel la cua ouais là vous avez
entendu des grandes personnes il ya
aussi des enfants qui participent à
radio de dos on a oui c'est super
intéressant
on va voir comment dans un instant on a
beaucoup de questions champs autour de
la femme mais beaucoup de questions oui
pouvait on va aller à paris je crois que
je sois sûr mais je pense sceptre paris
nous en recule devant aucune dépense
voici donc brigitte alepin à le pain qui
est à paris je pense de ta paris
brigitte n'est ce pas oui je suis à
paris j'ai la chance d'être à paris
aujourd'hui je suis bien content de vous
parler merci à quelle distance de notre
dame vous situez vous le pauvre qu'on
soit bien situer probablement cinq
kilomètres je vous dirai pas ça qui l'a
alors que vous êtes en libye n'a ni
je suis dans les studios de la station
de radio rosanna et qui diffuse radio
dodo et je suis il les bureaux de la
station de radio sont un petit peu
proche des portes de paris nice en radio
rosanna oui on va en parler on aura plus
de détails sera dur zana d'abord on
s'intéresse à vous parce que vous êtes
la fonte des neiges et vous avez ramer
fort aussi intelligemment
parce que la maison nous mangerons
lefort vous vouez agourram et plusieurs
façons vous avez été chercher beaucoup
de gens bien connus des gens vous savez
beaucoup de connaissances pour mettre
sur pied cette affaire là ça fait
seulement même pas deux ans ces cas nous
sommes dans notre troisième année
je suis un peu là-bas on peut dire je
suis la personne qui a eu l'idée de la
radio mais lorsque on lorsqu'on a party
la radio c'est on était plusieurs co
fondatrice toutes des femmes et donc eu
l'idée
l'idée m'est venue ça m'a pris plus
quelques années avant de penser à cette
idée là parce que dans le fond on
cherchait une façon de vraiment aider
les enfants
pas uniquement les réfugiés mais aussi
des enfants qui sont coincés encore dans
les territoires de guerre ou les
territoires du cil donc avec une radio
puisque les ondes radio traversé les
frontières salue ça me fait comme un
flash quand j'y pense à cette idée là
pour ses dix allons de l'avant avec sa
la ville d'alep en syrie tassez bien
connu le nom de famille alpin également
je pense qu'il ya un lien quelque part
oui donc c'est ça moi j'aime dire que je
suis moitié gaspésienne moitié syrienne
et m'appellent la partie de la série
c'est mon grand père qui est arrivé
d'alep
il ya deux cents ans est il lorsque tu
arrives et son nom et c'était
tabacologie et ce nom là c'était des
personnes qui est en a fait
hertz à des personnes qui voulaient
vraiment s'intégrer et lorsque lyon ils
ont voulu vraiment s'installer au canada
ils ont changé leur nom pour alpin de la
ville d'alep des questions autour de la
table en fait si vous lui permettez bon
situation de communication madame alpin
et a comme un émetteur et un récepteur
ce qui suppose un feedback
après trois années d'existence est ce
que on a des photos plutôt positif par
rapport à votre initiative
oui oui on a évidemment eu plein de de
feedback
c'est sûr qu'on a on aimerait en avoir
plus mais on est content avec les
résultats jusqu'à présent par exemple on
sait que vous faites au tout début radio
d'auto c'était pour des enfants de la
série c'est on cherchait un projet pour
des enfants de la série lorsqu'on s'est
aperçu que les enfants aimaient la radio
que dans le fond ça pourrait servir pas
uniquement aux enfants syriens
on a commencé à courtiser d'ordination
d'autres stations de radio pour diffuser
radio l'eau dans d'autres régions que la
série et pour d'autres enfants peut-être
pas uniquement les enfants victimes des
guerres mais peut-être des enfants
victimes de pauvreté ou des enfants
victimes de d'autres formes de violence
donc il a parlé à ce moment là on a
courtisé d une des stations de radio et
la première façon que le premier
feedback qu'on en a qui est vraiment
positif
un défi bac mena qui est vraiment
positif sais comment que ces stations de
radio là sont intéressés à diffuser
radio de dos par exemple comme on se
parle on a deux citations de radio au
bangladesh qui commence parle en ce
moment même il ya une personne au
bangladesh un canadien qui est en train
de faire cette heure de d'autobus pour
aller rencontrer une station de radio a
data pour les réfugiés et
donc aussi on a trois stations de radio
au nigeria on est au mali
on est en discussion avec des stations
de radio ou dans la vie de dakar donc le
feedback qu'on a des stations de radio
qui sont intéressés à diffuser ça c'est
extraordinaire je vous parle rien tantôt
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour des enfants
autochtones du canada
et donc c'est notre premier fait battre
l'autre feedback
ce sont les enfants les enfants
apprécient l'émission on peut voir si
vous faites le test moi c'est fait avec
nos petits enfants
donc il est sans fin notamment avec nos
enfants ils sèment la radio ils sont
relax
il y apprécie liant demande plus il peut
le voir sur notre site internet en tant
d'autres émissions parce que tout aux
émissions de radio des années
précédentes et de cette année sont
disponibles gratuitement sur notre site
internet
donc le feedback des enfants est
précieux on n'a pas tous les livres
écrits on sait pas exactement c'est quoi
l'audience on sait pas exactement
combien dans certains pays on peut pas
savoir exactement combien de personnes
écoutent mais ce qu'on a comme
information est très encourageant par
exemple on sait que plusieurs milliers
de personnes qui ont ouvert bien sûr par
exemple la station de radio de deux
chocs points 6e qui les radios à
montréal dont aussi on en sait assez
pour être vraiment enthousiaste dû
continuer radio dodo pour des enfants
sur des images récentes ou le ymca vous
a accordé un prix un grand prix qui a
marqué beaucoup je voudrais avoir
d'autres questions to data vous en aviez
une je pense oui moi je voulais savoir
puisque vous puisque vous intervenez
madame alpin puisse vous intervenez dans
différents endroits de la planète s
comment vous arrivez à adapter votre vos
émissions en terme de longues de contenu
ou d'âge ce que vous pouvez nous en
parler un peu de ça oui donc c'est une
vraiment une bonne question
effectivement il ya eu lieu
il faut adapter les émissions en termes
de contenu mais aussi même la langue
donc par exemple dans certaines régions
c'est un émissions en arabe qu'il faut
diffuser dans certaines régions c'est
notre émission les il faut s'adresser
aux enfants avec un émission en anglais
donc il faut cette année on a décidé de
produire trois émissions simultanément à
chaque semaine une en français une en
anglais et une en arabe est évidemment
puisque c'est un projet qui nous vaut
que ça on n'a pas vraiment de comparable
on apprend au fur et à mesure
présentement
pendant mon voyage je suis à paris je
vais parler avec l'ina qui est la
personne si rose chez radio hosanna qui
me disais oh peut-être ça serait bien de
le suggérer des choses pour notre
émission en arabe
donc on a juste qu'on s'adapte au fur et
à mesure qu'on avance et pour le moment
notre contenu y est strictement
québécois ce ne sont que des compteurs
que d'aider des artistes québécois qui
participent à l'émission québécois et
canadiens qui participent à l'émission
mais dans notre projet futur
je pense qu'on veut on va intégrer puis
on souhaite le faire intégrer des
artistes au niveau international mais
depuis la première année donc trois ans
ce ne sont que des artistes québécois
qui l'ont fait jaillir au niveau
international les gîtes
on va ajuster notre plan de caméra vous
allez faire la même chose de votre côté
à paris on va à faire apparaître
quelqu'un à vos côtés dont vous avez
évoqué il ya quelques instants alors de
radio rosanna on accueille la directrice
générale de cette radio lina chawaf qui
est avec nous bonjour lina jours alors
vous vous êtes un partenaire depuis tout
le début comment vous faites pour la
pour la diffusion il ya bien sûr une
partie web
est-ce que vous utilisez cette vieille
ce vieux outils des ondes courtes
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres techniques que
vous essayez d'utiliser des jetées par
des vieilles cassettes
écoutez un nouveau nationale on a fait
feu de tout bois pour essayer de joindre
notre monde en afrique alors on se pose
la question comment vous faites
oui on a dû refuser notre programme est
notre une formation sur les nus est sur
fm à la suite de turquie et nord de
syrie on a utilisé plusieurs plateformes
on utilisait le média sociaux on a
utilisé comme j'ai dit le web side et
encore le fn alors vous avez une idée
maintenant de l'impact que vous vous
avez comme radio au niveau de cette
programmation particulière qui s'adresse
aux enfants savaient des choses cela
nous communiquer désolé j'ai encore
demande comment vous êtes reçus sur le
terrain ça veut dire sur les fn n'ont
vécu telle est la réaction
le feed back with the bomb you française
on a beaucoup de gens des gens qui
appelaient sur sur corner et qui a
participé à l'achat à la programme et
qui a dit beaucoup de choses il ils
veulent participer vraiment à notre
programme les nôtres mon in show un
autre programme des enfants notre
programme des femmes on a appris qu'un
programme des femmes aussi
et il appelle partout de par tout le
monde et l'appel et il peut participer
[Musique]
de skype de whatsapp 2-2 en ligne normal
aussi
lina moi j'ai une question par rapport
aux thèmes de vos émissions
comment les choisissez vous et comment
vous assurez vous que ces thèmes là
allez chercher votre cible votre public
qui est principalement les enfants
peut-être que l'immense ce qui me permet
peut-être que je vais répondre à cette
question parce que c'est ici plus haut
niveau c'est plus à montréal qu'on
décide si ça va être quoi le contenu et
ça va être quoi le thème des émissions
donc au niveau de la réalisation de
l'émission en tant que telle qu'elle va
être contenue quel va être le thème quel
est le design de par exemple delà de la
saison au complet
c'est vraiment à montréal radio dodo
l'organisation qui s'en occupe
et lorsqu'on a un émission emmène a
envoyé à chaque vendredi matin on va
envoyer par exemple à rosanna ici à
paris l'émission qui est déjà tout monte
donc linda reçoit une émission complète
déjà monté danse pour diffusion sur sa
station de radio
mais comme disait un peu tantôt l'ena
les écoutes les émissions et à 10 est
comme je discute en tant que haut
peut-être qu'il faudrait faire un
contenu qui est encore peut-être encore
plus adapté à la réalité des enfants ces
liens
il faudrait donc c'est vraiment à
montréal que ça se passe au niveau du
contenu mais lina s'implique parce
qu'elle connaît bien la région et
connaît bien les besoins des enfants et
comment qu'on décide comment qu'on
décide en tant qu'un pour le contenu
pour répondre à votre question
en fait on pensait au tout début de la
première saison on faisait pas une
émission spécifiques à chaque semaine
sur un thème on faisait on n'avait pas
ce qu'on sait plus la première saison
mais apprécié on s'est dit pourquoi pas
en faire une émission qui à la fois
peut-être un petit peu éducative
donc on cherche des thèmes qui sont
neutres totalement noctua aucune
référence à la religion ou à la
politique à la largueur à la guerre à la
halacha la journée c'est ça les les
enfants syrienne mais ils sont tous sous
le trauma maintenant et c'est vraiment
très bien de faire quelques programmes
pour calmer comme on a dit sur radio et
tout le temps on a donnée à radio de
dole et les feedbacks de l' audience sur
le média sociaux sur le téléphone qui
m'a qui nous appeler et donnent leur ré
écouter l'hymne à remercier beaucoup de
vous être joint aujourd'hui côtés de
brigitte de le remercier
nous avons d'autres personnes belle
personne comme vous à découvrir on va
aller à un mariage comme ça c'est d'en
parler on va les faire la communication
avec une première intervenante qui se
trouve à montréal
sanaa ben dahmane veuille tendance
onesta vous avez des questions qui
portent
parce que là où puisque puisque on va
parler de l'émission de mourir donc je
pourrais réservé marc question tous les
réseaux voter chose alors qu'une
question par fusion alors est ce qu'on
est prêt pour notre troisième éviter
aujourd'hui à atteindre dans le canada
joue on est en java est une question
importante
je me demandais jusqu'à 6 et un très
important dans la conception des
émissions que l'émission ou la
plateforme soit interactive est de plus
en plus interactif auquel enfants non
seulement écoute soit rassuré mais qui
puise aussi s'exprimer sous à la grèce
bon vin d'estaing en attendant on joue
au jeu de la grosse boule alors on a on
va l'affiché à quelqu'un et je vous
prends mais vous n'allez pas perdre vos
points alors on va faire apparaître sur
quelques valley ratier mariko donc
monaco selon l'unicef en 2015 combien de
millions d'enfants dans le monde et est
considéré comme étant des réfugiés alors
à 7 millions b 31 millions
c'est 48 millions ou d aucune de ces
réponses et on a parlé de quatre
millions d'enfants syriens mon année ça
je me souviens de ça alors est ce que
c'est vrai pour le des réponses ou pas
c'est que c'est plus faibles moi j'irai
pour le sait le sait donc il si on a
quatre millions juste pour la syrie
ouais ouais j'imagine que ça doit être
importants mais on dit que l'aciérie
c'est l'événement
c'est là c'est là c'est la pire histoire
il ya bien sûr les roundup alors écoutez
12h30 médian 31 millions c'est la bonne
réponse bien sûr je suis sûr il faut
justement je ne suis pas vous faire
perdre ses points parce qu'écouter on
dit 31 millions d'enfants allemandes
étaient considérés comme étant des
réfugiés 17 millions étaient déplacés à
l'intérieur leur pays sont on le
considère pas encore comme des sujets
mais moi je m'en passe quand même à la
maison
c'est alors demandé à +17 ça fait quinze
ans que tu es tout le monde a la bonne
réponse personne ne perde pas juste
devant l'aca ne perdrait pas que c'est
tellement généreux alors voici notre
troisième éviter aujourd'hui sa main ben
dahmane
j'espère je prononce correctement les
animatrices bénévoles à radio d'audois
hockey et amant rien l'imaginé pas loin
d'ici même je pense à moins d'un
kilomètre nous on est très loin de paris
mais elle est très proche de nous elle
va apparaître bonjour comment ça va oui
d'accord c'est très silencieux
photo médecine qui est très silencieux
je trouve c'est briller sans parler
comme moi comment vous faites
oui je vous écoute je voulais juste
préciser je vous entends des en retard
donc si jamais je réponds en retard mais
c'est bien le dire à l'avancé on vous
entend bien alors que je sens qu'il ya
un délai d'à peu près 3 4 secondes
alors voilà il ya un délai de 3 4
secondes alors il y à notre camarade ici
samir ben crâne question pour vous j'en
suis sûr une l'a promis
donc avec sa nasse et sa salle à vous
qu'on vous préparez les émissions est-ce
que vous consultez les enfants d'ici ou
bien vous leur proposez où vous avez un
genre de focus groups que vous vous
consulté pour faire vos émissions je
parle des enfants d'ici du québec et du
canal canal à l'arrivée ce sont elles
les émissions on et décident tous
ensemble au niveau de notre contrée clip
de réalisation mais c'est sûr qu'on
reste attentif à ce qui se passe ça dure
en actualité on essaye de voir quels
sont les sujets d'actualité puis les
enfants dont vous parlez ce sont nos
trois animatrices en fait de trois
animatrices on essaie de voir elles sont
attentives à quoi à qui pour lui est
désintéressée et correspondent à l'âge
des enfants qui nous écoutent
donc on essaie de faire un bon mix entre
les deux pour trouver justement ce
problème et décider du choix des
émissions plus tard jusqu'à demain ça
s'adresse aux enfants quel âge radio de
dos entre 3 et 9 ans on essaie d'aider
oui vous avez une question avec
attention parce que lina mentionnait
qu'il y avait des enfants qui appelait
dès fois aux émissions est ce que c'est
important que les émissions seront
interactives
est-ce qu'il y en a beaucoup où les
enfants peuvent s'exprimer ou peut-être
même sur l'internet après l'exhibition
ce que ça ça compte énormément pour nous
écoute j'ai dû les émissions ne sont pas
diffusés en direct qui sont déjà montés
préparer le diffuser il sait après ea le
feedback et pour nous c'est vraiment
important de pouvoir savoir comment ce
que des enfants apprécient les émissions
pour vous donner un exemple la saison
dernière en produisait une seule
émission par semaine qu'ils étaient
traduites en simultané danse était
simultanément en français et arabe pour
nous en tant qu'adulte
ça paraissait safar et c'est le bon
choix du monde il faut des enfants et
après avoir reçu ces feedbacks justement
on nous a dit que des enfants ne
l'apprécié pas finalement parce que pour
eux etc
dès le contre en aval puis être
entrecoupé en français n'était pas
intéressant pour eux ce qui fait qu'en
s'est ajustée pour cette nouvelle saison
et du fait maintenant en produit trois
émissions distinctes pour chaque semaine
une complètement en français une
complètement en arabe une offre
complètement en anglais et c'est ça
c'est ça on n'a rien dit et ça en fait
grâce au feedback des enfants alors ben
salah sur un plan beaucoup plus concret
qu'est ce que ces émissions la change
concrètement dans le quotidien d'un
enfant un enfant qui est par exemple un
gain qui vit une situation de pauvreté
extrême qu'est ce que votre émission lui
apporte concrètement est ce que ça
change la morosité est ce que ça change
par rapport à son humeur
qu'est ce que ça lui apporte alors nous
nos émissions comme vous dites sont
dédiés aux enfants qui sont victimes des
guerres qui sont coincés dans des hommes
et on imagine sont tout le temps occupé
l'oeil mais l'actualité guerre bombarde
- et c'est donc nous à travers notre
heure d'émission
on ne rapporte un moment de trêve à
travers la musique et musique enjouée
qui descend crescendo pour les bercer
jusqu'au moment du sommeil il raconte
des histoires par exemple des histoires
de disney ou des histoires pour enfants
pour essayer de leur faire oublier cette
levée réalité qui est la réalité de la
guerre la pauvreté etc
donc c'est vraiment un moment de trêve
en commun à ses enfants pour qu'ils
oublient puisse dormir tranquillement le
soir sanaa merci beaucoup de nous avoir
apporté c'est vous qui avec les enfants
fait cette émission là c'est fantastique
de vous voir à l'oeuvre
est ce que un outil on a vu des images à
beaucoup de gens effectivement merci
beaucoup de vous être joints à nous
aujourd'hui
merci à vous je demande à brigitte on
n'a pas posé beaucoup de questions sur
radio choc qui est la radio de
l'université du québec à montréal qui
est ce c'est là où se trouvent les
studios ou autorise à faire l'un des
enregistrements multiples maintenant en
différentes langues
est ce qu'il ya des frais associés à sa
ce qu'il ya un an
puis financier qui vient de quelque part
même si tout le monde est bénévole comme
on fait pas beaucoup de choses avec rien
des fois donc c'est sûr qu on a le
privilège de pouvoir utiliser les
studios de choc depuis maintenant deux
saisons de radio de dos tout le manière
tout à fait gratuite et 6 passes justes
l'utilisation des studios qui est
exceptionnel de choc et de l'université
du québec c'est le fait aussi on a
vraiment un support on est vraiment on
rentre chez soi qu'on est chez nous à
titre d'exemple sanaa kit qui permet sa
maîtrise en sciences comptables à
l'université du québec qui fait radio
dodo en même temps qu'elle fait c'est
que terminer sa maîtrise elle et
supposons qu'on a en résultat fin de
semaine ce qui est fréquent parce que
les enfants qui anime cette année
peuvent pas enregistrer la semaine
puisqu'ils vont elles vont à l'école
donc supposons qu'on a reçu sa fin de
semaine
chaque vaut laisser les clés à radio de
doses ont été utilisées les studios
comme vous le souhaitez et ça va et même
sanaa au cours de son expérience a
appris à comment enregistrer des fois ce
soit elle même à l'intérieur à la
console technique et si elle même qui
fait lui l'enregistrement donc on a
vraiment un support incroyable je sais
pas si on en serait capable de faire
tout ce qu'on fait si on a des poses
ceux ci parlent de choc et du directeur
de choc de l'équipe de choc
c'est vraiment exceptionnel conditions
vous bien sûr on parle beaucoup de votre
votre oeuvre par humanité à travers le
monde mais vous avez évoqué il ya
plusieurs minutes le fait que vous
intéressait également aux autochtones
aux enfants autochtones en milieu
défavorisé au canada
dieu sait qu'il y en ait qui en a et qui
en est aussi écouter si on va simplement
au nord de montréal on en compte des
réalités qui sont absolument incroyable
pour des gens qui nous voir
après l'extérieur on va en parler plus
de ça dans quelques instants
mais là vous avez une quasi annonça
ferme ou jusqu'où on peut aller
oui certainement on peut dire plein de
choses que nous pour nous c'était
vraiment important d'aider les enfants
autochtones parce que j'ai donné cet
exemple déjà à l'occasion mais moi je
pense que avant d' aller aider les
enfants dans d'autres pays il faudrait
il faut voir nos propres enfants ici au
canada puis regardez comment qu'on peut
les aider
puis je pense qu'ici au québec les
enfants autochtones qui comme bien
d'autres enfants qui sont victimes de
pauvreté qui profitent de radio de dos
qui ne sont pas toc tonnes donc ici au
québec il ya des enfants qui pour qu'ils
écoutent radio de dos et et pour des
enfants autochtones
il ya deux cent soixante mille enfants
de 9 ans et moins au canada qui sont
dans les territoires autochtones et chez
ces enfants là et je sais comme noté la
radio elle est très populaire et très
appréciable c'est ce qu'on dit que le
tour d'infiltration de la radio est
extrêmement élevées donc nous aussi on
s'est dit pour l'année 2019 que on va
dédier notre saison aux enfants
autochtones et ce qu'on fait
présentement c'est quand on est en train
de rencontrer des radios communiquer
avec des radios autochtones partout au
canada pour signer des ententes de
collaboration pour que les radios
daptone diffusera dodo et on s'apprête
par exemple a signé une première entente
et on organise une petite fête à cet
effet là on va aller porter des radios
dans le territoire autochtone ou est-ce
qu'on va être diffusé pour la première
fois avec des jouets on veut que les
enfants autochtones participent
eux-mêmes à la radio pas juste qu'ils
nous appellent ou qu'ils nous envoient
des messages
on va à leur rencontre pour que
braquant radio dodo comme ça ils vont
être plus intéressés puis curieux entre
eux à découvrir radio de dos donc on
vraiment se déplacer vers eux et pour
nous oh moi personnellement je suis très
heureuse de pouvoir pour qu'on puisse
cette année ceux dédiés aux enfants
autochtones
vous avez toujours l'art de mettre les
mots dans la bouche on va se déplacer
justement au lac simon maintenant on va
les chercher
caroline amis se joint à l'équipe
aujourd'hui bonjour caroline alors
caroline d'écouté vous êtes consultante
en bon niveau des premières nations
l'homme que vous êtes la région du lac
simon spurr deux régions au plan
géographique 1 c'est incroyable c'est
les grands lacs c'est l'image qu'on se
fait du canada mais la réalité c'est que
si on passe du vol d'oiseau à ce qui se
passe sur le terrain
l'arrêté est difficile pour les enfants
beaucoup d'enfants il ya un projet en ce
moment de radio de doute on a évoqué les
principaux traits ya quelques instants
par les new deal de de cet endroit du
hac simon et des communautés autochtones
des endroits et des besoins
les besoins sont grands il ya plusieurs
initiatives qui se fait sur le
territoire depuis cinq ans on a amorcé
une démarche de développement de se
rapprocher via les arts et la culture
donc un projet comme celui de radio de
deuil est complètement dans les
orientations de notre développement
on a même créé une organisation qui
s'appelle ménages ce qui signifie en
année schnabel le bout puisque on veut
aller vers on croit que l'art et la
culture avec le bout dans nos relations
et on en a grandement besoin ici sur le
territoire de l'abitibi témiscaminque on
a pratiquement l'ensemble de la nation
algonquine sur notre territoire on a
cette communauté il y en a deux à
l'extérieur de la région
alors on a mis en place aussi des tables
de concertation aussi s'échanger des
bonnes pratiques et s'ouvrir un peu et
avoir de la liberté entre nous on sait
qu'on est dans un secteur où il ya eu la
crise à val d'or et à une crise aussi à
lac simon
donc on est dans des communautés
où on sait avec les pensionnats que kate
qui ont eu un impact complètement
dévastèrent on est encore danser dans
les résultats et l'impact que
colonialiste qui a eu par rapport aux
pensionnats alors là on est dans un
comme si le feu il reste une petite
brève pour rallumer l'envi de la culture
et rallumer un peu ce désir l'heure de
se reconnecter
alors tous les projets qui vont inciter
à éveiller l'envi de retrouver son
patrimoine retrouver ses contes et
légendes ne pourra être que de belles
occasions de mettre en valeur leur
patrimoine culturel et se le
réapproprier la radio est un vecteur
très intéressant il ya cinq radios ici
sur le territoire autochtone s'est bien
planté il ya plus d'une trentaine
d'années dans l'ensemble presque des
communautés autochtones du québec
alors nous depuis deux ans n'a fédéré un
peu un comité qui réunit l'ensemble des
radios pour voir comment on peut
utiliser ces métiers là pour rajouter du
contenu culturel donc du contenu dans la
langue dans leur patrimoine
alors la radio de l'action est une des
radios très active aussi et c'était un
endroit parfait pour amorcer un projet
comme celui là et il ya beaucoup
d'enfants c'est une des communautés a
pratiquement près de 2000 personnes
c'est une communauté où il ya beaucoup
d'enfants beaucoup de joie de vie vous
eu des fois juste noir il ya beaucoup
une belle solidarité et un centre
culturel il ya une radio ya pas à wau
lyon des sites traditionnels à la rose
l'a fait il ya aussi de compter une
question oui en fait je vais sortir un
peu de des préoccupations de radio dodo
pour parler de la situation de pauvreté
même des enfants autochtones c'est une
situation qui a fait l'objet de
préoccupations nations unies l'onu qui a
maintes fois interpellé le canada sion
la nécessité d'agir de mettre plus de
ressources dans la lutte contre la
pauvreté touchant ces enfants là
est ans consultante sur le terrain
quelle est votre appréciation de
l'évolution de la situation avec
l'arrivée du gouvernement libéral qui a
promis pas mal de choses pour améliorer
la condition des communautés autochtones
partout au pays
est ce qu'il ya comme un changement il
ya beaucoup à faire et c'est énorme les
montants qu'ils doivent être investis
pour faire du rattrapage une urgence à
tous les niveaux moi je suis plus actif
au niveau de la culture mais je sais ce
niveau là de se créer des
infrastructures des lieux tout ça les
besoins sont partout et on sait que si
on cible l'éducation qui est en lien
avec les jeunes
c'est un vecteur pour de survie mais
lorsqu'on n'a pas les besoins de base
qui qui sont comblés et si encore la
réalité a claqué que la communauté
voisine de lac simon il n'a pas d'eau ni
d'électricité
alors cédé des montants énormes qui
doivent a est revue et augmentée huy ha
vu quand même pour vous le soulignez ya
eu des améliorations conserver j'en ai
marre conservateurs mais aussi quelques
commerces qui reste qu'on attend les
suites à ce niveau là haut niveau plus
politique
on espère maintenant aussi sur la langue
une voix pour protéger mettre en valeur
la langue et l'angleterre au pays est la
première de ce territoire se faisait
aussi partie des des attentes que les
communautés ont actuellement mais du
fait des investissements massifs
puisqu'il ya du rattrapage de plusieurs
milliers d'années sous financés dans
l'ensemble du québec dans tous les sens
il nous reste une minute
moi je voudrais revenir à la radio alors
une question pour brigitte et carly en
même temps alors du contenu adapté aux
enfants je reviens toujours au contenu
quand comment vous imaginez le contenu
de radio de dos pour les enfants
autochtones au lac simon
si je peux me permettre car j'allais
dire
j'allais dire parce que ça me donne la
chance de dire quelque chose qui me dit
que je voulais dire la question est
à tombe à point parce que pour les
produits ses missions pour les enfants
peu comme puisque c'est l'année des
langues autochtones
c'est bien certain que même si les
enfants autochtones par exemple parle
soit français ou en anglais dans
dépendamment des communautés on va
utiliser notre émission en anglais ou en
français mais on va l'adapter pour les
enfants autochtones et comme disait
caroline ya tellement de contes et
d'histoires passionnantes dans l'ansé
communauté là que évidemment on va
ajouter des contes et des histoires
volent des communautés autochtones aux
émissions est également c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire
dionne la radio du lac simon caroline
avec raymond qui à la radio du lac-simon
pendant que je parlais moi je parlais
moi même au téléphone avec cette
personne n'a eue avec caroline puis il
me disait c'est personnel j'aime ma
demande bien pourquoi pas faire des
clips découper les émissions puis faire
des clips plus petit ou est-ce que qui
dure peut-être cinq minutes ou est ce
que on a une histoire puis peut-être une
chanson qui suit ou est-ce que qui
pourrait être joué durant la journée
pour finalement créer un habitude auprès
des enfants et c'est extraordinaire vous
savez avec les gens du lac simon on a eu
1 ils nous ont partagé cette idée lock
on a on va utiliser puis qu'on va faire
pour eux et pour d autres les autres
régions de la planète
mais s'agit-il va falloir ce qui t'es là
dessus mais c'est quand même des grands
projets que vous y a des gens c'est
fantastique on a fait le tour un peu de
votre jeune monde
et puis vous avez voulu vous dire aussi
une belle nous donne des nouvelles
en étant j'ai eu la permission de vous
dire que ubisoft et igg radio de dos
sont en discussion pour que parce que
ubisoft veut supporter radio radio de
dos dans sa mission de devenir vraiment
une radio internationale qu'on a
vraiment besoin d'un tremplin en ce
moment pour accomplir ce grand rêve
donc c'est de la nouvelle on vient faire
la nouvelle panacée non la peau s'il
peut toujours c'est le souhait initial
alors bonne chance merci beaucoup et
j'ai talpin d'être venu aujourd'hui tous
les collaborateurs de radio de doute
merci à vous merci avocat bruno meier
bonne journée à vous également
on va il a fallu attendre la pluie
également sous le nom du québec tient au
lac simon en ce moment sur sur une
journée c'est un peu comme ballast il
pleuvait beaucoup ce jour là et puis on
est fait pour notre dernier jeu de la
grosse boule 50 points à perdre
l'aïe a conduit ouais mais j'ai 80 70
vous avez rive-de-gier personne qui a
perdu deux points la deuxième question
c'est le débat c'est du jamais vu
enfin s'était trompé quand finalement
vous savez ce qui est du jamais vu c'est
qu'il reste quatre minutes avant que
cette coupe on écoute pas on la fiche
puisque vous complétez cette phase 2
points au canada les enfants autochtones
sont conviés pour cent ont les plus à
risque de vivre dans la pauvreté que les
enfants non autochtone voilà à 25% b 33
% c'est 50% et d'écouté alice mans parce
que moi j'allais avec 50 1% 5 ans pour
cela qu'un pouvoir faire confiance à
rades et sagem safran doit tout ça pour
personne a perdu deux points
je ne sais pas des questions très drôle
mais c'est des questions font deux fois
plus ouais ils sont au moins deux fois
deux fois que les enfants non autochtone
c'est ce qu'une étude de concluait la
une et une seule puce en canadien de
politiques alternatives vous êtes
intéressés à ce jour si vous allez sur
la page web de tam-tam canada cette
semaine vous allez retrouver d'autres
par leur art c'est que le rédigé par
madame cette collection est question des
réfugiés j'ai noté oui c'est vrai c'est
une problématique qui m'interpelle
énormément les gens qui vivent des
conditions vraiment difficiles à voir à
partir de chez soi parce que on n'a pas
trop le choix parce qu'on cherche et de
meilleures conditions de vie
je trouve que c'est quelque chose
d'assez préoccupant qu on vous a
présenté intéresse puis vous évidemment
une déformation de métier avait autre
chose je vais à loucher par rapport aux
réfugiés ont dit reste quelques instants
moi je que ça vous laisse je voulais
savoir j'ai pas eu le temps cette
semaine j'étais très occupée rien faire
c'est de savoir ça s'occupa n'ont rien
reçu berson lagarde
alors ok en syrie on a par mois dans les
médias
ouais quelle est la situation au niveau
des réfugiés avec handling en ce moment
oui en tout cas ce que tu veux non pas
la version courte
alors je suis mal placé pour parler de
noms mais je suis sûr que je sais que le
plus grand nombre de réfugiés il est
vraiment dans la région dans la région
de la syrie c'est vrai qu'au canada n'a
reçu on a reçu des milliers de syriens
mais là la majorité s'il reste encore
sur place je vais pas vous poser de koch
vous êtes le plus renseigné de l'apparat
laisse évidemment je veux pas m'avancer
quand je n'ai pas les chiffres
je pourrais parler des autochtones et
d'un reportage que je vais publier
aujourd'hui un beau reportage sur la
tradition du sirop d'érable la caméra
elle est très fière de son reportage
elle est apparue à personne mais tout le
monde a noté que ça sort des cétacés
dans le système on a vu apparaître de
venir et de l'écouté ouais tu es passé
pas mal de temps vous êtes allé là bas
oui on est allé jouer en contre je
n'avais plus de l'espèce autochtone
oui il reste quand seconde lamy à la
dame
[Rires]
[Musique]